So this week we're talking about archaeology and we asked your students in the
introduction
activity to produce their signature, kind of a strange thing to do, right?
So do your signature.
There's my mess of a signature and we asked them to do that multiple times.
Well, why?
Because when an archaeologist is digging and what archaeologists do is if you have
an excavation site, you have to dig below.
Well, what happens when a city falls?
It crumbles to the ground, it all falls in.
Well, it's not like today where if this whole entire building came down,
then we would clear
the rubble,
send it to recycling facilities and rebuild and level the ground and start
all over again.
They didn't have those capabilities.
So if a city fell and all the rubble sat here,
they would simply level off the rubble and
build a new city right on top.
And we keep doing that year after year after year or decade after decade or whatever
the
case may be.
So as archaeologists are digging, they're digging below each of these levels,
each is
called, it's an archaeological tell, is what they call it.
And they're digging into, well, they have to use clues to figure out if they started
digging here and they found something,
that's going to be from a different time period
than if they dug down here and found something.
So the signature is a way for your students to help understand that if they found a
piece of paper with my signature on it and they figured out that it was me with this
big
mess of a signature, they would know that, let's see,
based on the fact that I used an
expo marker, the fact that I'm on a white board, the fact that it's black, all these
factors, plus they would connect it to me, could figure out roughly the date or at
least close to when this actually happened.
Let me give you another example.
This is the Hulkbuster and full disclosure, this is mine, not my kids.
If this whole building collapsed,
let's say we were in the ancient times and they had
Legos in ancient times,
and this whole building collapsed and they found pieces of this and
they put it back together and discovered that it was this.
Based on the kind of Lego this is, based on the character, the fact that this is
Iron Man and the Hulkbuster suit, that they would pretty much know exactly when this
Lego came out, roughly when it got built and what era they're currently digging in.
So that's the importance and kind of what archaeologists do.
And we want your students to start thinking about what that looks like, okay,
this isn't
necessarily Indiana Jones kind of stuff, but it gives us a good idea of how this
is done.
So when they come across biblical artifacts,
what does that mean for the biblical text?
So for your storyteller, this is a really cool opportunity to have someone come in.
You don't have to have an archaeologist, you don't have to have anybody that has
an amazing discovery.
If you can, that would be awesome.
If you happen to have somebody in a local seminary that has done some traveling to
the Middle East and Jerusalem and whatnot, that'd be awesome.
But if not, that's okay, don't worry, like you have to have that.
You could simply have somebody that was rummaging around in grandma's attic and
found
a really important family heirloom.
Years ago, my grandma was moving from her condo to a long-term care facility because
she was getting ill and needed to be watched, pretty much 24-7.
So my family all got together and we were kind of going through all of our stuff.
That's a little bit weird when she's sitting there watching us go through all of her
stuff.
But it was fascinating because we found all these really cool artifacts and there
were
stories behind it and it was stuff that reminded my dad of his childhood and kind of
what that
meant and we talked about really interesting stories and we had a really great time
walking
down those memories.
But if you could just find a storyteller to even tell that story, it helps connect
the importance of discovery and archaeology and artifacts and all those pieces of
history
with what we can know about the Bible.
Because my dad can tell me a story,
but when he connects it with an artifact or something
from his past, that story becomes that much more reliable, because it could just be
he remembered it wrong,
but it also becomes that much more powerful because I'm understanding
that what he's telling me is now actually history.
And that's exactly what we're hoping your students get when they look at archaeology
and scripture.
So for small groups, your focus is simple.
I want you to focus on helping students see that this Bible is also history.
Yeah, it's the word of God.
Yes, it's inspired.
Yes, it's completely accurate in every way because God made it that way.
But God also made this a accurate reflection of history.
What goes on in here is actually historical.
We have found coins that give us indication that David actually was a king.
And we've seen things from the New Testament that have the inscription of Pontius
Pilate
on it that remind us that Pontius Pilate was an actual person.
He was an actual governor.
He actually was the one responsible during Jesus's crucifixion.
There is history behind it all.
And we want your students to kind of drill that in,
but I also want you to pay attention
to their questions because now that they're starting to see scripture as something
that's
a little bit more important than maybe they thought it was, there's going to be some
pushback and some thought that, well, isn't this just a bunch of stories and myths
that maybe people thought were true?
And there's some sort of evidence that maybe they just kind of messed around with
history
and they just kind of messed around with the truth a little bit.
There's going to be questions and you need to be ready to answer those questions and
talk through them a little bit.
But I want you to continue to walk students down that road of helping them
understand
and see the importance of this book and what it means for their lives.
So I'm going to leave you with one final question that I want you to leave your
students with.
Two weeks in,
what does this information from the biblical reliability to archaeological
evidence do for how you see the Bible?
Think about that for yourself because if you didn't know some of this information
prior to these last couple of weeks and now moving forward with your students,
think about that with yourself.
Does this change how you see it and don't be afraid to share this with your students
and help them see like, hey, I didn't know either.
I didn't maybe I didn't know all of this.
Maybe I'm not.
This is new information for you as well.
Share that with your students.
Walk alongside them, especially encourage your small group leaders to do the same
thing so that they can see that this isn't something that they ought to know
and everybody should know and they're just kind of out of the loop that
this is a journey for all of you.
And the more you understand, the greater that this book becomes.